enfin je peux vous parler de ce projet
et même vous le présentez ce que vous
allez voir c'est un épisode d'une série
qu'on a tourné avec pierre corner pour
la chaîne ci ont sévi tv alors en gros
en deux mots la série s'appelle
bestioles et dans chaque épisode pierre
m'emmène dans des endroits avec des
bestioles des animaux de ouf et je suis
jamais préparé à ce que je vais voir
histoire de garder un maximum de
surprises et de voilà c'est à chaque
fois ultra intéressant surprenant tout
ce que vous voulez c'est à base de
serpent de poulpe de milliers d'insectes
bref j'ai ultra hâte que vous voyez ça
là je vous mets un épisode entier une
aura également quatre à sortir
directement sur la chaîne youtube de
sciences et vie tv alors un jeu vous met
les biens dans la description et vous
pourrez retrouver la suite de la série
directement à la télé sur la chaîne donc
si on s'évite tv tous les samedis à
20h40
ok c'est une chaîne qui se trouvent dans
les bouquets sur les box etc vous
connaissez la chanson merci à tous et
bon visionnage salut à tous et si
neumann aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer à
un sujet qui me fascine totalement il
existe ainsi dans la nature larmes la
plus remarquable qu on ait jamais vu une
arme biochimiques qui peut tuer
paralysés ou tordre de douleur un
adversaire
une sorte d' arme fatale en somme je
veux bien entendu parler du venin et
pour vous en apprendre un peu plus sur
ces substances hors norme laissez-moi
vous amener au palais de la découverte
plus précisément à une exposition de
poison allez venez avec moi
venez avec moi
[Musique]
fou
je vous cache pas que l'arrivée au
palais se fait avec une légère boule au
ventre ou s'apprêtent à rencontrer plus
de 30 espèces qui sont à cause de leurs
poisons parmi les plus dangereuses du
monde
on y trouve des araignées des serpents
des scorpions des scolopendre mais aussi
des plantes des oiseaux des grenouilles
sérieusement des plantes et des oiseaux
alors oui il faut faire une différence
fondamentale entre poison et venant un
poison ou toxines biologique est
simplement une substance qui causent des
dommages à un organisme 1 venant est un
poison qui est produit par un animal et
qui est destiné à être injectés dans ce
cas là on dit qu'une espèce est
venimeuse comme les serpents ou les
araignées mais un organisme comme une
plante ou une grenouille peut également
contenir du poison dans ce cas là on
parle d'espèces vénéneuse à
d'inoculation ok elle peut transmettre
son poison par ingestion voir simple
contact a besoin de te mordre ou de te
piquer en gros et en même temps mordre
pour une plante c'est pas évident sauf
si tu es dans jumanji là ça passe et le
premier spécimen que l'on rencontre ici
est une grenouille et mieux vaut pas
l'embrasser pour chercher un frein seule
souche ou pis quoi c'est trop génial
mais pourtant c'est très dangereux
compte ouais ça c'est le coco vie de
colombes c'est une espèce venue nous
deux
de grenouilles et notamment en amazonie
dans lesquelles on les trouvait on prend
des flèches manière point des flèches
mais ça l'a complètement chose hélas si
je la touche avec mon doigt il faut que
je gère non ses contacts et en gestion
contacts déjà t'es pas bien c'est fou ça
ouais
de quoi est composé le venin pour être
si puissant un venin est un mélange de
différentes molécules actives un bon
gros cocktail bien vénère ces molécules
peuvent avoir différents effets mais les
plus connus sont les neurotoxiques qui
vont agir sur le système nerveux et les
émaux toxiques qui vont altérer les
cellules sanguines et jouer sur la
circulation du sang vers les tissus
la belle bleue l'a71 dendrobates elle
est vraiment magnifique
elle s'appelle dendrobates parce
qu'elles se baladent sur les arbres
d'andros ça veut dire arbres en grec et
bat ça veut pas dire qu'elle joue au
baseball 1 ça veut tout simplement dire
allez marcher en grec également entendre
bat marche donc sur les arts et quand on
parle venait on pense tout de suite à
ses représentants les plus emblématiques
les serpents y en a qui ont commencé a
pu être sur un ça va
le premier serpent que pierre a voulu
montrer est un crotale diamantin de
l'est une espèce de serpent à sonnette
et pour le coup malgré son nom pas la
peine d'appuyer dessus pour qu'ils
viennent vous ouvrir n'essayez jamais ça
fait peur mais en fait tu es ça c'est
mignon quand je regarde ces petites
landes qui sort comme ça
nous venons qui justement très puissant
très toxique
le venin est sécrétée par un organe
spécial une sorte de glandes salivaires
modifier un canal à rely les crochets à
cette glande une fois sur deux environ
le serpent venimeux n'injecte pas sont
bonnes alors de la morsure
dans ce cas on parle de mort sur seiche
il s'agit pour lui de garder son venin
qui est précieux pour se nourrir c'est
tout un cocktail de protéines qu'elle va
injecter dont le son de la victime mais
c'est pour ça qu'ils vont en faire un
usage avec remonte parcimonie colin et
là c'est une vipère du gabon une des
plus grosse espèce de vipère au monde
elle fait vraiment flipper avec son
camouflage quasi parfait et ses crochets
pouvant atteindre jusqu'à 5 cm c'est un
serpent vraiment très dangereux pour
l'homme accrochez-vous maintenant je
vais vous faire rencontrer le boss du
jeu d'un game le mamba noir son surnom
annonciateur de l'agonie ça pète son
venin neurotoxiques et le plus efficace
des poisons
il agit sur les nerfs et provoque une
paralysie générale la quantité de venin
qui est libérée dans une morsure
peut-être gargantuesque
c'est un mot que j'adore ce gars est
quand tu es sq tient et pour ceux qui
vont la réf tout ce que je viens de dire
est tirée d'un film bien connu du truc
c'est intéressant et là je pense que
c'est le pire moment pour s'approcher du
mambas noirs parce que je sais pas si tu
vois son oeil si lui des yeux nous en
fait il va muer de l'intégralité de sa
deuxième voie l'audio voit le voile on
voit là que cette peau elle va elle va
pouvoir être du coup bas parce que
vraiment elisson l'état cause à
n'importe quoi qui l'approchent belle
attaque est compressé un des serpents
les plus dangereux du monde sait ça en
fait le venin qui est sécrétée dans les
glandes dans sa bouche
c'est un des plus importants mais c'est
aussi une espèce qui injecte beaucoup de
20 ans d'un coup quoi ça balance la
purée c'est ça c'est mon papa de m plus
inspiré 18 min litres ce qui est au ski
à l'air très peu montré pour du venin
ces jeux tu approches une sereine avec
cette humilité d'un liquide tu fais pas
le malin parce qu'une seringue classique
c'est quoi en fait bah c'est quelques
quelques 20 millilitres au plus quoi
jouer donc c'est énorme a annoncé céder
des grosses gouttes bon bah voilà
j'adore les serpents c'est faux et voilà
c'est la fin de cet épisode j'espère
qu'il vous aura plu c'était trop cool de
voir que le venin n'est pas qu'une
substance nocive mais qu'il peut être
utilisé dans plein de domaines comme la
médecine ou comme un rat temps ça me
donne une idée nico j'ai une nouvelle
idée de concept pour ma chaîne
t'inquiète pas ça à bien se passer c'est
juste à base de piqûres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié voir cet
épisode en tout cas de l'autre côté
c'était à chaque fois systématiquement
trop cool a tourné et a eu des frayeurs
vraiment comme quand j'ai vu pour la
première fois le black mamba par exemple
il ya eu des super moments vraiment
beaucoup plus fort en émotions comme
quand on a pu par exemple relâcher des
animaux soigner à l'école vétérinaire
c'était génial
ou quand j'ai par exemple non je vais
pas vous spoiler non plus la série 1
voilà pour laisser un peu de mystère tu
préfères que vous découvriez ça par vous
même merci à tous pour votre soutien
merci à tous de me permettre de vivre ce
genre d' aventure c'est génial j'espère
que vous allez apprécier la série encore
une fois pour nous c'était un énorme qui
va faire donc merci à tous pour vos
futures retour n'oubliez pas c'est dispo
sur science et vie tv et moi je vous
laisse car la science n'attend pas salut